- [Voiceover] In this
video I want to talk about
the System of Jim Crow Segregation,
which was common in the United States
from about 1877
to approximately 1954;
although, it goes a little
bit further than that.
Now, you're probably familiar
with some of the aspects
of Jim Crow Segregation from
the Civil Rights Movement.
Jim Crow Segregation involved
the loss of voting rights
for African Americans,
as well as, separate
public accommodations,
and by public accommodations,
I mean all sorts of public
spaces in American life.
So, this might be transportation,
separate areas in trains and buses,
or hotels,
bathrooms,
swimming pools,
water fountains.
So, these places in public life,
where African Americans were put
in the place of a
second-class citizenship.
Where they could not experience the
full range of movement,
job benefits, protection of the law,
or really any of the aspects
of American citizenship,
that are the benefits that
come with paying taxes
and abiding by the law.
And during this period of Jim Crow
this kind of segregation was legal,
this was not just in practice,
but encoded in the law.
So, where did this System
of Jim Crow come from?
Well, let's start with the name Jim Crow.
Jim Crow was not the name
of a specific person.
Actually, Jim Crow was the
name of a stock character.
A stock character is kind of
a basic well-known character,
in usually a comedy, and we
still have stock characters
in comedy today, in lots
of different forms of entertainment;
Think of, the absent-minded
professor, or more recently,
the manic-pixie-dream
girl, the girl who is going
to change your whole life
by being so off-the-wall.
Well, Jim Crow was one of these characters
in a form of entertainment
called the minstrel show.
And the minstrel show was a very popular,
kind of vaudeville-type live performance.
The minstrel show was
actually very popular
in the north of the United States,
places like New York City.
And in the 1830s, 1840s, kind
of this antebellum period,
before the Civil War.
So, this character of Jim Crow
was supposed to be kind
of the stupid slave
who lived on the plantation,
and this character of Jim
Crow was almost always played
by a white man wearing
black makeup on his face.
So, it was not an actual
African American person,
but rather a caricature of
an African American person
by a white man who was
part of a minstrel troupe.
And so the name, Jim Crow,
became kind of synonymous
with African American's
and with enslaved people
in the early 19th century,
the way that say Patty became synonymous
with an Irish person.
So, the term Jim Crow Law,
or the Jim Crow System
means laws that were specifically aimed
at African Americans.
Alright, so that's the origin of the name,
but where did they system come from?
And for that we're gonna
have to do fairly deep dive
into American history,
and I won't be able to
go into everything here
but let's kind of look at this
from the thousand-foot view
and get a sense of the
overall pattern of slavery,
the Civil War, and race
relations after the Civil War
to see where Jim Crow starts.
Now, I've been daring here
and done a vertical timeline.
The first thing we have on here
is the end of the Civil War.
Now, before the Civil War
in the southern part of the United States,
which I have outlined in red here,
most of these states had legal slavery.
And in these states,
or the colonies that preceded them,
starting about 1620,
they imported African
slaves to be unfree laborers
on cash-crop plantations,
and these might include tobacco,
or cotton.
And that system of slavery persisted
until the balance of
power between the north,
where slavery was largely illegal,
and the South, where
slavery was the backbone
of the economic and political system.
Eventually it tore the country
apart into the Civil War.
In 1863, Abraham Lincoln,
the President of the United States issued
the Emancipation Proclamation,
saying that all enslaved people,
and the states which were currently
in rebellion were now free.
But it wasn't until the
end of the Civil War
that slavery's end was official everywhere
in the United States.
And the end of slavery
really posed a problem
for the states of the South.
Now obviously this was a wonderful thing
for people who had been enslaved,
now they had full freedom
to move, and work,
and marry whomever they
pleased, at least in theory.
But it also meant that
the system of slavery,
which had dominated the
politics, the economics,
the social system of the
South for more than 200 years
was now over, and something
had to replace it.
So, in the immediate
period after the Civil War
the question is,
what are race relations going
to look like in the South?
How will whites and blacks
relate to each other
without the system of slavery,
which has dominated the entire region
for more than 200 years?
And we'll get into that in our next video.